quelques avec les vidéos c'est qu'on
peut se compter qu'on veut on adore
venir avec moi son concert suivi du
ouais tu concert privé quinze personnes
max alors par contre il est décédé
donc c'est faux en fait il a rejoint
carlos dans les étoiles
bisous l'artiste keith est ce que vous
voulez tu as toujours ton mobile home au
camping de la palourde alors voilà on se
demandait s'il était disponible mi
juillet c'est chiant ce que tu fais tout
ça c'est quoi pour toi chez rossini
complet avec le jour 4 me [ __ ] c'est
chéreau ils sont les jours 3 me ils sont
les nuits 4 me
peu importe son unique et la gueule non
c'est vraiment une [ __ ] oui
montmagny
robin d'inscrits